bonsoir mesdames monsois revue
demoiselle crossouard crayeux 3 heures
du matin tout les temps je tourne en
rond dans le salon avec le doigt sur le
piano je fais de gaza les faux quand
t'es pas l'âge ne soigne pas quand ce
n'est pas l'âge de poule
tu vois seulement besoin d'un peu de toi
bonjour madame combien ces petits pulls
dans la vitrine c'est pour un petit
baigneur ou pour un grand c'est un
secret impeccable pour l'hiver
voilà ma fille je m'excuse roland mais
ici on est où c'est votre bureau central
des idées l'atelier sketch à nous non
pas du tout ici c'est le bureau du chien
il s'agit donc d'une petite chaîne
s'appelle rustines c'est petit et zack
hall ça pour ça qu'on l'a appelée
rustines elle est sympa comme tout elle
a six mois et demi ça fait pas très
anglais pour yorkshire estime christine
c'est pour rester français le côté vélo
de la faire bon alors si ce petit chien
vtt un mal je l'aurais appelé robert
c'est un animal vous l'avez choisi alors
je les acheter j'avais envie c'est une
compagnie c'est sûr et puis c'est un
être vivant c'est assez troublant ou
troublant dans le sens où c'est capable
de temps breizh aussi d'agressivité
enfin c'est exactement comme nous on
retrouve les mêmes paramètres et ça
c'est assez troublante intéressante
qu'elle véhicule
utilisez-vous si l'on peut dire pour
vous mettre à sa portée un langage
délibérément débile ou des mots très
courant d'hommes à chelles déjà pour
mettre à sa portée il ya un truc qui est
relativement je me suis aperçu très vite
on dis ces petits chiens il elle monte
sur les fauteuils en fait c'est pas
qu'ils aiment forcément les coussins
mais il faut déjà être à leurs auteurs
je crois que c'est important
alors je sais pas comment je lui parle
parce que
je dois être un moment donné ou à un
autre un petit peu débile l'extérieur
c'est évident en tout cas déjà c'est de
se mettre à sa hauteur ce que c'est des
petits chine donc et je sais que les
rapports sont très bons quand si elle
est partie en moi je m'allonge par terre
on signe contient peu l'existence
quotidienne de rusty sans oublier un
environnement affectif bella est là ma
vie c'est à dire que henvic et oui elle
fait j'ai beaucoup de choses elle se
couche tard elle se lève tôt il ya des
matins où elle a promis de se lever mais
elle m'accompagne partout c'est à dire
que bon ben on voiture tout va bien
quand je prends le
l'avion là la prends l'avion avec moi et
comme elle a été habituée tout petit
tout va très très bien
et puis elle adore ça parce que ces
petits chiens sont les chiens qui sont
très finalement notre l'impression qu'il
n'y ait pas du tout sourire très calme
très observateur très curieux et pour un
chien curieux la vie que je mène c'est
formidable parce qu'elle a de quoi voilà
alors cette rustine l'est qu'elle reçoit
une bonne éducation votre part vous
posez la question notamment sur un
problème actuel c'est une certaine idée
du respect des trottoirs est ce que je
veux dire oui
alors ça je dois reconnaître que j'ai vu
un petit balcon chez moi alors que j'ai
la chance de jouer faits sont coincés au
balcon il y en a qui mettent des chaises
longues mois elle a son coin le problème
de la pollution canil ça vous intéresse
la plupart de cette [ __ ] de questions
non non c'est à dire que je crois
qu'effectivement il ya des il ya des
toujours gênant quelquefois de voir des
trottoirs qui sont qui sont souillés par
les chiens bon c'est vrai mais je dire
il faut pas non plus exagérer parce que
avant de faire des grandes campagnes
contre les chiens
je crois qu'il faudrait déjà faire des
grandes campagnes pour que les gens
arrêtent de balancer des papiers gras
des paquets de cigarettes
quand on s'est fait des bêtises vous
êtes pour ou contre le châtiment
corporel châtiments corporels je dire un
chien d qui fait une bêtise
le comportement est tout de suite hop on
va dans son coin
donc je crois que c'est pas la peine de
ça ça doit se passer dans le regard mais
pas jamais que le châtiment corporel
sert à rien ça sert à rien sur les
humeurs il avait fait c'est pour chien
c'est pas très grave mais aussi les
coups et les blessures ça c'est autre
chose
ah oui ça c'est une rencontre sera très
loin c'est révoltant
les on voit souvent effectivement il ya
eu beaucoup les journaux as et
sensibiliser les gens à ce genre de
problème et je pense que ça c'était
important
il ya aussi le cas des maîtres des
animaux qui gagnent leur vie et leur
pâté ensemble au cirque au music hall au
cinéma alors ça n'est qu'un jeu mais
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais moi
j'ai travaillé avec un chien
dans un film c'était l'idéal parce que
le chien on lui demandait de rien faire
et c'était un chien qui ne faisait rien
donc tout le temps était parfait mais
les chiens dressés
je crois quand même que ces chiens là
doivent en baver quelque part un jeu
c'est un peu comme les femmes et les
enfants ça aime les types drôle
alors quand vous travaillez votre numéro
chez vous devant l'éternel place salle
amusé russie au niveau des répétitions
ça lui fait un petit peu peur parce que
quand je répète je parle fort et quand
on parle fort elle n'a pas l'habitude de
me rendre par l'effort donc en fait à
l'aise je pense qu'elle n'a pas très
bien conclut encore ce qui se passe est
comprends pas pourquoi quand je lui
parle directement l j'utilise un langage
normal est parti au moment où
quelquefois je me met à hurler tout seul
dans l'appartement
alors dans ce cas là elle préfère
changer de pièce le papa il a une petite
graine on lui
et puis la petite graine ça lui
chatouille
elle donne un titre et d'un moment est
ce que la cour oui oui ça nous en a mais
je crois qu'en général les géants
l'humour mais ses mémoires des jeux
c'est pas la face ouest arthur n'était
pas encore question délicate
est ce qu'un jour ou l'autre vous
permettrait aux rustines de recevoir la
petite graine pour calcus avoir des
bébés bien sûr sûrement sûrement ça fait
partie tout ça ça fait partie de la vie
je crois que c'est c'est important et
s'il perd le bébé quand le touche
c'est une fille ce que vous en ferez
tous ces bébés
je crois que je trouverai parmi mes amis
toujours quelqu'un qui dit orale le
coeur pur pour les élus est question
triste
on raconte que mozart a été accompagnée
seulement par un chien sa dernière
demeure qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette histoire c'est le meilleur ami de
l'homme
c'était en tout cas son meilleur ami
sûrement je crois que c'est un flash
mais c'est un flash qui est qui et qui
est réellement profond c'est vrai que
c'est plus qu'une compagnie je crois que
c'est que ces deux vies c2i cqcd couple
tout ça je disais qu'à lui même créée
elle elle me disait oui mais toi est-ce
que tu m'aimes
et moi je disais oui mais toi question
grave
ah bon s'il ya un enfer pour les chiens
méchants et un paradis pour les autres
un mois je ne veux pas y aller en enfer
1 mais paraît qu'ils m'ont déjà repéré
là haut
est-ce qu'il y en a pour les hommes
méchants et un pour les autres pareils
il paraît peut-être ma progression je
crois qu'il s'est toujours passé quelque
chose à mon donner de la vie d'un homme
ou d'un chien qui a fait que tout d'un
coup on a mordu où on s'est défendu où
on a attaqué on verra bien mais bon on
va tous se retrouvent bientôt faire
alors la seule petite différence c'est
qu'on fera tout ça c'est sûr dès le
choix d'alsace quand t'es pas l'âge ne
soient pas tentés pas l'âge pour pouvoir
seulement besoin de tes de toi